Black holes. Yeah.
So do you wanna have a chat about how supermassive black holes grow?
Which is what I've been up to basically is figuring that out. So.
Well, let me tell you what I think happens. Go ahead.
Don't they just sit in the middle of galaxies and just,
just nibble up anything that comes to close. No.
It can happen. They do just sort of get gas funneled to them in the galaxy.
The thing is there are very massive, supermassive black holes in the universe,
and also we see them at incredible distances.
So I very early on in the universe and there is a limit to how fast
black holes can grow. Just by what we say, accreting material.
It's sort of like how, when you pull the plug hole out of a sink,
all the water doesn't immediately go down, right?
There is some pressure that stops all of the water,
just forcing itself down like a bottleneck, right?
You have a bottleneck around a black hole essentially as well,
but we'll get there eventually, Ella we'll get there eventually. Yeah.
But there's a certain limit to how fast that can happen. So for example,
we see supermassive black holes as early on as 800 million years into the
university's lifetime.
Unfortunately it's not enough time to build a black hole in that way.
In the early universe, you see a black hole that say a billion times,
the mass of the sun, right?
If you think it's had 8 million years to grow that big,
the liberate that it will be limited to.
That's physically not enough time for it to go that way.
And then you've also got things in the universe today.
Things like MSCI 87 black hole that's, you know,
tens of billions of times the mass of the sun is huge. Right?
And so people think, well, how did it get that big?
Now the one correlation that we see is that the massive that black hole is
correlated with how big the galaxy is.
So it's like the two have grown up together essentially, right?
So if you add more mass of the galaxy, you add more mass of the black hole,
but there's also a link between the size of the black hole and the middle part
of a galaxy. So if you picture of a galaxy, it's got that sort of disc shape,
and then it's got this central bulge and it's even more tightly correlated with
a massive that central bulge now where those bulges come from is from
mergers.
So two galaxies merged together and you redistribute all the annual events and
the energy in that galaxy that kept all those stars on nice sort of circular
orbits that we see. You can take it.
So those stars are basically sank towards the center. And instead of on,
you know, nice ordered orbits, they're on sort of like chaotic orbits,
like a beehive,
but you can imagine that in a merger when stuff obviously then does sink to the
center in this redistribution of energy,
then that material will also feed the black core.
And you'll also get the two black holes merging together.
Are you saying the reason supermassive black holes can grow bigger than they
should is because of mergers.
And they gobble up a whole other black hole because I would have thought with
the bathtub, with the water going down,
if I suddenly came along with another bath tub full of water and just poured it
on top or in it still wouldn't be able to get down that hole any quicker.
You're not dumping the other black call onto what we call the accretion desk,
which is sort of the bath tub of water. That's trying to spiral in.
You've almost merged the two pluck holes. So you've made the plug hole bigger.
So not only have you grown the black in that way,
you've then almost made it easier for it to, uh, create more material, right?
Because you've made it so that it has a bigger gravitational pole and it can
take more in.
So this is why people think those are so tightly correlated is because you get
the merger and you get extra growth from it.
And then you see that in the fact that the bigger that bulge gets,
the bigger your black hole gets as well.
So much that by the time you get to galaxies that are all bulge, you know,
these elliptical galaxies that are perfect steroids that have had all of that
nice rotation destroyed in lots and lots of mergers over their lifetime,
they tend to have the biggest buck calls. And so over a long time,
people are like, that's how black holes grow. They grow emerges.
Look at this correlation.
Anything that doesn't have a bulge or has a very small bulge has
piddly black holes, right? Because it hasn't had any mergers. Exactly.
And because all it was able to grow with was your way you said at the start,
which was just sort of happily taking in whatever was around it.
And the work that we did, first of all, in my thesis,
and I've followed up in the past couple of years as well was we took the
galaxies that don't have a Bush. And we said,
let's look at what mass those black holes actually are. Now.
You might've thought well, that would have been a really obvious thing to do,
but they're very, very rare. These galaxies, we, first of all,
had to wait until there was a huge catalog of all the shapes of galaxies out
there that we could use,
which came with a classification site called galaxy zoo.
Hopefully some of your viewers will recognize it was the website that got people
to classify the shapes.
That's still going still needs help if people are up for it.
And with that sort of database, you never in a million galaxies.
We could start with, to look at, we ended up with a hundred of them,
of these things that didn't have bulges. So that just shows how rare they are.
They're also things with growing black holes as well.
So the way you get at the max and you actually measure the mass of the black
hole is you measure how fast the material that spiraling around it is going,
which means it has to be actively growing for us to be able to spot them.
So when that happens, that material starts to glow.
This is what we call like a quasar. When it's gray, like going very,
very brightly, right. Sometimes goes in the x-ray,
but also it can go in the obstacle. And so when that happens,
you also get emission from hydrogen gas.
And so you've got the sort of radiation coming from this material that then
impacts the atoms and hydrogen excites the electrons.
So if you remember chemistry from GCSE is you have your electrons in your
orbits, they jump up one.
And then when they drop back down there and it has very specific color or
wavelength of light. And so if you were to take a spectrum of that gas,
that's orbiting around that galaxy where you split the light,
you would hopefully see this giant peak at that hydrogen color or Waveland.
What you see though is instead of it being a very specific wavelength,
it sort of smeared out and that's because half of the gas is coming towards you.
So it's blue shifted and half of it's moving away from you. So it's red shifted.
So if you can imagine how far that gas has been, sort of Schmid out,
you can measure how big the black court is because we know how fast the thing is
moving. You know, how big the thing is moving around,
which blew my mind as a PhD student being like, Oh,
look from this line that does this.
I can tell you how big the supermassive black hole is.
This seems like a lot of room for error in this process, but yeah,
but it's still possible.
So we looked at these things and we found that they obviously didn't lie on
this correlation of black hole mass in bulge mass,
but this is the line where this is everything nice. He sits.
And he has the most massive things,
the most massive borders and the most massive black holes,
all our borderless things were over here.
So these are galaxies that haven't had mergers that have somehow grow in that
black hole, just as big without merging with any other black holes. Well,
how to do it. Exactly. So this is what we're now trying to figure out, right?
Is that yeah. Okay. We go back to this idea of, okay,
black holes can accrete material that's around them,
but it's limited to how fast it can do that. Fine. But how does it,
first of all, get there.
So the galaxies we're looking at with these Borgias things,
they're very pure sort of spiral galaxies. They've been left alone,
their entire lives, right? So a lot of them have beautiful spiral arms there.
Some of them have these bar structures in as well.
And so the leading hypothesis is that they funnel gas in and they funnel stuff
to the center. Now,
all the work that's been done looking at the limit of the black hole was
obviously done in other galaxies and not in this.
So there are some ideas that that could be different possibly,
and that could be affected by the properties of the black hole.
The paper had last year was trying to work out what rate that material is being
floated in up basically. And whether that will affect things slightly.
So we looked at a small, a number of these galaxies looked about 10 of them.
I somehow managed to call them after Harry Potter characters in the paper.
I got that past the referee. And I was very, very pleased with myself.
It was all about what color I'd highlighted them on the page,
like to observe that night,
it was like the red ones had to be observed on Tuesday night.
So they were all named after Griffin doors, the green ones of Wednesday nights.
And it was literally when we looked at these galaxies, what we found was that,
um, their accretion rates of the black hole, the amount of material,
these black calls we're taking in we're five times higher than in, uh,
a sample of galaxies that had undergone these mergers.
But the crucial thing was is that unlike a bathtub where all the water
goes down, the park hall,
can you imagine if you took out the plug hole and the pressure around it
built up so much in that bottle neck, that it threw water back at you,
this is what black holes do, right? I like to say that they burp, essentially.
They're trying to take in so much at once that the easiest thing to do is that
pressure builds up and builds up is to throw some material back out.
Now doesn't come from the black hole.
And that's what confuses a lot of people is it happens before the material,
you know, reaches that event, horizon that point of no return.
What we found is that in galaxies that have had these huge mergers,
you reach that pressure point sooner.
And so actually you have the Burt point. Exactly.
So these galaxies that have mergers are actually burping up five times more than
our galaxies, that haven't.
So our got axes that haven't are still birthing a little bit.
They're just not doing a giant megaphone.
They're actually taking in more material than the ones that have had mergers.
Cause the ones that had mergers or just throwing most of it back out again.
So it's almost like if you've had a merger,
the black holes a bit more full and doesn't want to eat as much.
Exactly. Yeah. It's already merged with another one.
It's like I've done and the galaxies, but it is work for theater.
Then you end up with this huge book. But the thing is,
what also happens is that, um,
the ha the faster a black hole itself spins the more efficient it is it
accretion and th that they can push up that limit. So, and this is very,
this was a very important thing that we concluded in this paper was that if you
think about how the black hole is actually getting this material and a galaxy
that hasn't had a merger that's been left alone has its nice pure desk.
It's all coming in from the same angle.
And so it's always going to spin up and spin up and spin up the black hole,
whereas in a merger of two galaxies,
that funnel stuff towards the center and syncs up, present it,
that's going to be coming from all different directions. And so wasp.
Sorry, could you be more English?
These? Yes, no,
but in a merger where you've had two galaxies merged together and all that
material is coming from all sorts of different directions,
then that black hole is going to be getting some material from this direction,
which will spin it out this way, but then some material from this direction,
which will spin it back the opposite way.
And so what we found was that the sort of average thing that was probably
happening is that emerge the galaxies,
the black color is being spun down as we call it,
it's being averaged back to zero. Whereas in our borders, galaxies,
it's being spun up all the time and it's accretion is getting more efficient and
that's what allows them to grow so big because it's sort of like the sort of
slow and steady tortoise rather than sort of the greedy hair in a way.
I didn't know,
material from outside of black hole could spin up the black hole that way.
I thought once it crossed the event horizon, like all information is lost.
Parrots, the angular momentum of the material that falls in,
which is quite cool,
these results that we had were done with what's called narrowband imaging.
So instead of taking a spectrum of light where you get sort of the emission from
one specific element, instead, what you do is you say, okay,
given the Redshift of that galaxy,
I know this element submission will be around about this wave once.
And so I'm only going to let in light from that specific wavelength and take an
image in that narrow strip. And then from that you can sort of then work out,
well, how much energy is in that? Because all of these burps,
they tend to be very energetic and they will, um, excite these electrons,
but in oxygen, in the galaxy, right? So if we can just observe oxygen,
then we can just get it, you know, what's going on in that bit. But again,
what you need is this data where instead of just taking one spectrum,
either from the very center of the galaxy,
you can split it into a jigsaw and take lots and lots and lots of them.
So you not only can find out where the sort of birth emission is and therefore
work at how much there is of it.
You can also figure out what impact it's having on the galaxy,
around it as well. Cause that kind of throwing back out of energy,
back into the guide. So you can then have a huge effect on the galaxy itself,
right? It can heat gas up that you need to make stars.
It can expel gas from a galaxy. So there's huge repercussions.
So it's really important to understand the,
how this tiny little process can have this huge impact everywhere else.
And what's interesting to me, is that like, okay, yes,
mergers were almost like the low hanging fruit that was easy to spot.
That was like, this is clear what's happening.
But it seems as if this sort of funneling of gas is happening in every galaxy
all the time,
but then you only see the after effects of the merger because it's so apparent.
Right? And that was like the key thing that happened that you noticed first,
we had some simulation friends as well that simulated this happening and they
showed that 65% of all the stuff,
all the matter that's currently found in supermassive black holes in the
universe got there because of this funneling processed in
galaxies, not because of mergers.
So we've sort of flipped the hypothesis on its head that black holes grow by
mergers. And we're like,
actually looks like the majority of the time that ain't what you said at the
beginning, right? Just happily taking them whatever's given to them.
So we are in the black hole laboratory. What you're looking at,
that's an analog rotating black holes.
They are about 2000 liters of water in there. If you follow me here,
we have a toolbox which we can open.
It was really thin the picture of her majesty,
the queen, which is just the vague shadow.